our next topic
is examples of vectors last time
we simply looked at the basics like you
know what's a vector how do you refer to
its entries or its elements
we looked at the concept of equality
stacking vectors
let's see what else did we talk about um
that is pretty much a sparse vectors
unit vectors ones vectors special
vectors yeah
um at that point however
there'd be no reason for you to have any
interest whatsoever like
who cares what do you do with a one's
vector like who cares um
right now what we're going to do is
we're going to look at some examples and
this will hopefully give you a rough
idea of
the kind of where you would see and
encounter vectors
um hopefully you'll end up convinced
that it's in a whole lot of applications
uh that vectors come up okay um
so let's go to some of the most uh
traditional and classical ones right if
you take uh your you know a first course
and
actually sometimes in vector calculus or
if you take a course in
physics or mechanics or something like
that um
there you encounter a lot of vectors
those vectors are usually
uh two vectors or three vectors meaning
that they have dimension two
or three uh i mean in the real world
it's like three
for us i mean if it's if it's positions
and there
what people talk about is uh you can use
a vector to
to give a location right so for example
here's a vector x um and it's got two
entries of course it's uh it's a two
vector so it looks like
x1 and x2 and what they represent what a
vector here represents is a position in
a plane and that's that's this picture
here
so you should think of it as telling you
that that dot or the position is there
so a vector can specify a position um
in two dimensions or in three dimensions
too so
uh of course you have to agree on what
the coordinate system is
you know and it could be whatever
doesn't matter it could be
you know the traditional one uh but you
have to say what the coordinate system
is but once you give the coordinate
system
a vector a three vector will give you a
location okay
or a two vector would give you a
location in a plane that kind of thing
so that's
that's very common and you've seen this
i think these are called you know
cartesian coordinates that's
that's what this is okay um now a very a
related concept
not quite the same a related one is um
you can use a vector to describe
displacements right and a displacement
does not refer to a position
what it refers to is a uh actually a
change in position from one place to
another so there
we when it's describing a position we we
think of it as
we draw it as a dot or an x or something
a when we talk about a displacement it's
usually drawn as an
arrow and the basic idea is here
x1 x2 as in here represents a
displacement and it says that
you know from this point to that point
you should move
uh to the right by x1 and you should
write
above height by x2 and that's a
displacement
um so that's uh this this is the kind of
thing you would see
in your you know in your basic physics
class or mechanics or something so
that's
and this is very conventional and you
probably saw this already and things
like that
okay um let me mention some others and i
actually frankly find these
more interesting um okay so first of all
color colors that the human eye
responds to are given by three vectors
so three numbers r g and b
um and that's the red green and blue
intensity level
and it's very cool so you can describe a
color
by giving by giving three numbers
for example uh the first unit vector e1
means it depends how you scale it but
i'm gonna scale them so that one means
maximum intensity
zero means off okay so in that system
e1 which is the vector one zero zero is
the color
pure red right um
then e3 is pure blue
um the vector like one
zero one means turn on the red full
blast
turn on the blue and you're gonna get
some very pretty kind of violet or
purple color
that's what it is but this would give
you all sorts of colors uh that's and
they're described by a three vector
okay another good example is sometimes
an n vector is used
to give like a bill of materials or a
list of quantities
so for example um you could have
10 raw materials that you need to
just to to build a unit of a product
right
and then a vector could describe how
many of
how many units of each of the materials
you need
to build the product right and so that
would be that
super interesting question there is if a
vector is sparse
that means that the list of quantities
you're describing most things are zero
um so that's an example that's a good
example of a sparse vector
um here's one a portfolio in finance
right so it's very common but it's not
very common it's universal
it is universal in finance uh when
you're describing a portfolio and a
portfolio is a collection of assets that
you own you know typically stocks
bonds options it doesn't matter whatever
they are
and what a portfolio does is it's a
first of all it's a collection of things
that you own
um and there it's represented by a
vector
and the several ways people do this uh
it could be that a vector would give you
the uh a vector could give you the
dollar value
of each of the assets that's a that's a
common one
another one is it could give you the
fractions right um
of your total portfolio uh in in held in
each of these assets right
it's also interesting we're going to
talk about this later maybe not so much
right now
that you can actually have negative
quantities in finance right and
what that means is these are called
so-called short positions and it
basically means that you borrowed it
from someone
and you're going to have to pay it back
so but we'll talk about that later
but it's interesting because it means
you can have quantities that are
negative
in this case right so let's just look at
an example
so here's a portfolio with let's say
stocks bonds and cash
just keep it real simple right so here's
a portfolio and i'm going to represent
it
i'll represent it in dollar values it's
100 50
and 20. there you go so that
portfolio says that you have 100 worth
of stocks 50
worth of bonds and 20 in cash that's
what it means
okay and that that's a very common way
to uh represent
a a portfolio so that's the idea
um but so that that's it you for example
we can look that and we can say what's
the total
uh what is the total value of that
portfolio
and it's the sum of the entries and that
would be 170. so if someone says how
much is your portfolio worth you'd say
how much is this portfolio worth you'd
say 100 percent okay oh sorry
170 dollars okay um here's another one
uh a vector can be used to represent a a
cash flow
um and that's very interesting very
extremely common right
so um a cash flow could be
an amount it could be all sorts of it
could be the revenue
for uh one of your stores okay and
it's the daily amount of cash that came
in by the way a bunch of cash is
probably
also going out but that's you'd have to
specify which cash flow you're talking
about
um it could be the payments on a bond or
a mortgage or a loan
we'll see these are all like cash flows
so a cash flow is something like
either a payment to or a payment from
you uh in various periods in time and
here by the way the index is sometimes
referred to as the period and
it could be anything it could be days it
could be quarters
it could be years it doesn't matter
depends on the application
but that's a very common thing where x i
is a a payment
um so interesting question already um
what does it mean if a cash flow vector
is sparse
that's that's my question i mean at the
moment we don't have a whole lot of
concepts but we have a couple and we
might as well tie them together so
that's my question to you was what does
it mean of a for a cash flow to be
sparse
well it means this it means that let's
say it's a cash flow vector let's say
it's a hundred long
so that means these are the payments
made in a hundred different periods
let's say it's months or something so it
goes out about eight years or whatever
it is eight and a half years
so that's a that that that's a hundred
long vector in this payment if it's
sparse it means that
in most months there is not a payment
either by you or to you
which is kind of interesting right so if
it had like five non-zero entries
uh if they're positive they could
represent a payment that
is to us and if it's negative it could
be a payment made
by us and so that's what it would mean
to be to have a sparse
cash flow vector okay um
audio so sound um so sound
uh is in fact uh what it is is it's uh
it's it's very fast
variations in the fresh air pressure uh
which your eardrum
uh which your ear picks up and your
brain
you know allows you to perceive as sound
and so there are several ways to to uh
to encode sound but one is by the way as
a vector
and typically what it is i mean the most
common format is this
it's a very long vector these are not
short vectors right these are long long
vectors
but so basically what it is is it gives
you the
sound pressure level at various
instances of time and those instances of
time
are separated by a very small amount of
time around 25 microseconds that's about
44 000
uh per second i mean there's other
formats too it could be 48 kilohertz 22
kilohertz and
this just means how many samples you
have per second but nevertheless that
that's what it looks like
so that's what a that that sound
sound is a vector right and so uh for
example an
entry of a an entry of a sound vector
would tell you what is the acoustic
pressure at that particular moment
by the way the acoustic pressure again
you don't need to know this but the
acoustic pressure is
the actual pressure at that moment at
that exact moment in time
minus kind of the average pressure uh
it minus the average pressure at that
time and so it can be positive or
negative that's
and that's typically what it is so um
okay so audio audio track that's a uh
that that's a that's a vector um here's
an insanely this is
a super useful and common one is you can
use a vector to describe
so-called features this is basically the
entire core of machine learning
statistics many other fields but the
basic idea
is that a vector stores a bunch of
numbers
um each of them are either called
features or attributes
of a of an entity right so for example
i'll
i'll give you one let's say that the
entities correspond
to a patient being
admitted to a hospital right the first
entry
could be something like their weight
that would be x1
x2 could be their height
x3 could be their diastolic blood
pressure an x4 could be their
uh you know systolic blood pressure and
so on and so forth
um we can also do things like have some
encoding
so for example we could in code
x5 could encode the sex of the patient
and we could we could assume we'd have
what we'd have to have would have to be
a convention but we'd say something like
x5 equals plus one if it's female if
if the if the patient is female minus
one
if male right so that would be uh an
example
but it could also have a lot more uh a
lot more things in it and feature
vectors
can be sometimes small with just 10
entries
but they could be super big right
so as an example we could
do something like this let's suppose
that let's talk about feature vectors
for let's say publicly traded companies
right
so google has a vector so and here are
the kinds of things you might find here
are the kind of attributes it could be
let's say they're their total
capitalization the volatility that's how
much the price of that thing has wiggled
around over the last year
it could be the last quarter's return uh
it could
be altered it could be their revenue it
could be all sorts of things
it could be the total number of
dividends they paid in the last quarter
so these are all
attributes uh of of companies and then
we would have a lot of vectors and they
would
they would all each one would be
associated with the company and so on um
and now you'd know what the entries
meant okay um
next example is uh customer purchase
that's a super interesting uh vector
right there
so you're some kind of a store
well let's say you're amazon um then
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
take a single customer and you're gonna
ask over some period like the last year
how much or what's the total dollar
value of the en
of what they bought now the length of
that vector is actually going to be
each entry in the vector is associated
with a skew right which is a unique
id for a product that you can buy right
so
uh so these vectors could be big
these could be like a million long uh i
once knew
what the amazon uh what what the number
was for amazon
actually it was less than i thought it
was but it is not small let's put it
that way
okay it's millions um but but the idea
there
is then for a customer like me we could
look up and figure out what have i
bought in the last year and
it would be represented as a vector now
by the way that vector will for sure
be super sparse right because of let's
say the 1 million things that i can
order on amazon
maybe it's 10 million whatever anyway
for whatever it is
i may have ordered a couple hundred
things but i did not order i didn't
order anything close to all of them
right so so that would be a natural
example
uh in the wild of a sparse vector and in
fact it would be stored as a sparse
vector right it'd be a list of things
that look like
you know the skew and then the quantity
you know and that for us it would be a
vector that's a purchase that's a
customer purchase vector
um and that comes up very very often um
here's one word count um that's a very
interesting one
now we have a document we're going to
see a little bit i'll say a little bit
more about that in a bit
i have a document and what we do is we
simply
count we also have a dictionary and we
count the number of times each word in
my dictionary appears in that document
and that gives me x i so x i is
literally
the number of times word i appeared in
the document
okay could be zero and by the way if
it's sparse it's interesting
sparsity there means that whatever your
document is
most of the words in your dictionary did
not appear
so that would be that would make sense
if your dictionary
was like you know a typical english
dictionary might have 50 000 entries
um and suppose you're processing uh
reviews of products okay well they're
they're a paragraph or so right and i
pretty much guarantee you that
most of the 80 000 or 50 000 words in
english do not appear
in each review so that's once again an
example of a
sparse vector various parts vector so
um let's look into that in more detail
and see how that works so
here's a short document right here i
mean it doesn't say much it's actually a
snippet of text from the book
um and so it's got a couple of sentences
in it
uh and uh here's our dictionary our
dictionary and we have to agree on the
dictionary that's important you have to
say what the dictionary is
and the dictionaries of course is just
be given by a list of words so our first
word is well
it's work our second word is in
our third word is number okay and then
this
that is the word count vector
associated with this document using
this dictionary okay so let's audit at
least one entry just to check
let's try uh v okay
so here it is that's uh that's the uh
let's go look up to the document and
scan it and see how many times that came
up well and i hope i'm
i hope this works out right so it's not
in the first line
oh oh oh oh there's one two
three four okay so four occurrences
and sure enough that's represented right
here that's that okay
so this is the uh this is the idea
is it that uh fifth entry in the vector
which tells you how many times the word
the appeared in your document
is four in this case right now i should
add
this is just a baby example right
dictionaries
are typically have a thousand entries um
oh and they sometimes have a catch-all
entry call called
not in dictionary so in other words if
you have some other weird word
it just counts as a special word called
not in dictionary but
these are that's a detail um common
dictionaries are thousands
too and then some cases even like a
million okay
so dictionaries can get very uh very
very large
um and but it's interesting right
because
you can imagine i could take a
shakespeare play and i can write
i can get a word count vectors probably
15 20 maybe 15
000 different words appear in it and it
would be represented by a 15 000
vector right um and that would be sort
of the
the idea very interesting so we're
talking all sorts of stuff you can do
with word count vectors
uh later in the course but just it's a
good
that's one thing that a vector that's
one thing that a vector can represent